Mày tính sấu không quân của Khoenah Thông Báo đã bán hả một chiếm mấy bây chiến đầu xú bà mâm lắm của Ngà tại tình khuốc.
Đây là một trung những sọng mấy bây hiện đại nhất của biên trế lực lượng không quân ngà.
Thế tuần bấu đăng tải trên trế lây quân bú bán hả dính ra chung khuột khổ một trình dịch được mưu tả là thành công của Khoenah.
Mùa 1 tín độc lập từ Ngà đã sắc nhận và cho biết phi công đã được cử sống.
Sở kênh này dính ra tiếp nối trình dịch mặc nhẹn nhằm vào các khăn cử không quân của Ngà dấu Khoenah Công bấu.
Vìa ổ quênah Tuyên bầu đã phá quý, khoảng lắm hương hại ít nhất 1 mốt mấy bài quân sử,
trong đào con nhiều mấy bài nền bông trữ lượng.
Tuy nhiên phía ngà đã lên tiêm bác bỏ con số này.
Các bạn video dầu quênah Công bầu cho thấy các ua bê đã tính công nhiều mục tiêu trong lãnh thủng,
à. O quênah cũng cho biết các ua bê này được phóng đi từ các sê tài cải trang gần cân cử.
Lấy thị thải lớn về kỹ tài quân sự của ngà.
Fíng át dynh bầu đã đầy lùi phần lớn các cuộc tân cân và đang xem xe các biển pháp đắp chá.